*Chewbacca noise*
I know your family's waiting.
*Angry Chewbacca noise*
I know it's important day!
* Whining Chewbacca noise*
For God's sake, use your adult words!
*Sigh*
I'm sorry, Cinema Snob, it's just I'm so excited!
It's the Star Wars holiday sequel and we're totally retconning the problems of the last one!
We're not going anywhere unless we outrun that giant slice of pizza!
Why don't you just jump to light speed? That's always the answer.
Oh yeah.
Why does it always take me so long to remember that?
Critic, we're home.
Yup.
[Critic]: The same old coloring book cover that we're used to.
Come on, I want you to meet my extended family for HUAAAnukka.
Oh god, they're not a bunch of Wookies like in the last special, are there?
No, I told you Snob, we're doing something completely different this time!
OH HELLOSA
Sir Jarjar!
HONEY WESA GOTSA COMPANY!
WESA GOTSA COMPANY!
*Chanting* WESA GOTSA COMPANY! WESA GOTSA COMPANY!
[Snob]: I could use a Jefferson Starship cameo about now.
[Sir Jarjar]: Now yous sitsa here
and watch things while I go and makes the dinners.
*splorch*
OHH PEEEYEWSA
PEEEYEWSAAAA
So what do we watch?
Holiday specials?
Ohh, no no no
We partake in the most classic of HUUUAAnukka traditions.
We just sit around and watch stuff that has absolutely NOTHING to do with the holiday whatsoever.
Oh look! The Force Awakens is on!
I see what you did there
It's very subtle.
[Critic]: The highly anticipated sequel to the now poorly named sci-fi trilogy is here.
Star Wars: The Force Awakens
[Snob]: Can it make up for the siths of the past?
Will there be a special edition where CG characters are replaced with puppets?
[Critic]: And most importantly, will it lead to even more holiday specials?
More?!
Come on; Halloween, Easter
Wouldn't you love to see how Jarjar celebrates Black History Month?
I'd rather drive with Jake Lloyd.
This is The Force Awakens!
[Snob]: So it starts off with- ah hold on a second
*SLAP SLAP SLAP*
[Critic]: So unless someone out there can't read
[Snob]: Then how would they know to click on the video?
[Snob]: It starts off with a rebel spy giving secret information to a little droid
just before Storm Troopers come in and separate them.
[Critic]: Wait
That sounds eerily familiar.
Road Chip has the same plot.
Really?
PFFFFT
Who knows? You'll never see it to find out.
[Critic]: Instead of the Empire this time, it's the First Order
[Snob]: Which is just another name for Empire, isn't it?
[Critic]: Pretty much.
As one of their leaders, named Kylo Ren
tells them to put the pilot, named Poe, on the ship and kill everybody else
[Kylo Ren]: Put the pilot named Poe on my ship and kill everybody else
ESPECIALLY Max Von Sydow!
AAAAAAHHHHHHH
This would be zero-zero-one
DUGGHH
What's Harvey Korman doing in this?
Oh, he's a robot that let's us know when a good actor is completely wasted in a role
Number two-six-five
Gone but not unforgotten.
[Snob]: Does that happen a lot in this movie?
Does the Jedi menorah have nine light sabers?
*BWOO*
[Snob]: But one Storm Trooper, named Finn, is SHOCKED that being a psychotic killer
means being a psychotic killer
So he breaks Poe out but gets shot down to planet not-Tatooine
where Finn presumes Poe's dead as the ship sinks into the sand.
...and blows up
*BOOM*
[Critic]: Perhaps it was allergic to sand?
It is very coarse, rough and irritating.
And it gets everywhere.
[Critic]: This is when we meet Rey
a scavenger waiting for her family to return
who comes across the droid named BB-8
Well, aren't you an adorable soccerball with a Storm Trooper's butt cheek on top
*Pew!*
[Critic]: But the not-Empire finds the droid too, causing her to run into Finn
and the two of them team up trying to escape
They come across the Millenium Falcon, which is confused for scrap metal
It belongs in a museum!
[Critic]: And they take off in it, seeing as how apparently none of these ships require keys of any kind
[Snob]: Of course, all the tie fighters ditch them because only the drunkest of soldiers pilot those things
and they escape into space
Well, because the galaxy is such a "small" place, they bump into Han Solo's and Chewbacca's ship
*CHOMP*
[Snob]: Hnyur wait a minute
What's with the animation all the sudden?
Well, through certain camera lenses, some people look like poorly animated cartoon characters
Nuh-uh not happening
*snap*
*POOF*
*TA-DA!*
[Critic]: Wait a minute, how is that possible?
You're watching the special with me.
THAT'S your biggest question?
You're not concerned why the Jarjars are watching gay acrobatic holograms?
OOOOHOHOHOHO
*splorch*
EW PEEYEWSA
[Critic]: You just don't understand HUAAnukkah.
Yes, because you've never explained it to me.
It's not something you explain
it's something you feel
*exasperated sigh*
I feel like a Scotch right now
*off-screen splorch*
[Sir Jarjar]: *unintelligible* PEEYEWSA!
[Critic]: So Rey and Finn explain their situation as Solo agrees to help them
to get the droid to the not-rebels
*DING DONG*
...aaafter he's attacked by some people he owes money to
Just hide here until this pointless detour blows over
Pointless detour?! That ties in perfectly with-
HOKAY TIME TO WATCH THE HUMAN PORNOGRAPHIES I HAVE FOR SOME REASON
*splorch*
OH PEEYEWSA
How is that even possible?!
Well, this should fittingly explain how pointless this scene is.
MMMmm, angry men wanting their money back
ooohhh
Giant octopuses that come out of nowhere MMMM
None of it... ties into the story
oh yeahh
But it's still shorter... than the opening of The Return of the Jedi
*SNIFF*
MMM
*vaguely sexual grunt*
ALL RIGHT
[Snob]: Are you sure this isn't the porno version of Star Whores?
No, I think the plot would actually be more focused
[Critic]: So Kylo Ren talks to Supreme Leader Snoke and-
HOLY SHIT
What the hell is that?!
Oh my god that's the new Emperor?!
He's gigantic!
HOLY SMOKES imagine the possibilities you can do with this!
[Kylo Ren]: SUPREME LEADER
I am sorry we have to talk to you via non-cost effective gigantic hologram
*In unison* BOOOO!
That's for making me think you were awesome!
Well- who knows! Maybe it still has a pretty good design
*dramatic build up*
[Snob]: I thought I said no more cartoons in this
...Actually, I think that's supposed to look realistic
[Critic]: Yyyeeah, remember that cheap-ass alien from Kingdom of the Crystal Skulls?
He's your Emperor now!
Except somehow he looks even... faker
Not to mention a whopping seven lines from the actor you're never allowed to see act
Ouch.
Even the name Snoke, it sounds like an eighties' cartoon
about a bunch of colorful creatures that live underwater!
[Critic]: But he does at least let out this important bit of information:
[Snoke]: BY THE WAY HOW IS YOUR FATHER HAN SOLO?
*DUN DUN DUNNN*
Are you all right?
Anyone else get a "you're so dead" vibe right now?
N-not really.
In fact, I'm getting more of a "two more movies" vibe to be honest.
Yeah, it's probably just you.
That's exactly what I'm afraid of.
*DUN DUN DUNNN*
*Outro sting*
*And we're back sting*
[Critic]: So after finding out that the villain has a father-son relationship with one of the good guys
we go to a cantina where a ton of weird aliens hang out-
OKAY
None of this if ringing a bell as having been done before?!
Oooohhhh, I see where you're going with this
*flatly* I'm Bea Arthur
welcome to my watering hole
Please tell me no more about your watering hole
I wouldn't talk, eraser head
ALL RIGHT settle down
[Bea Arthur]: You're not even a real fighta
You wanted to always run
So what if I do?
Finn! Don't let her think that
Only fools and cowards run
Now, we hear you might have something that'll lead us to Luke Skywalker
Sure do
*oh nooo*
Go to run
*SWEET CATCH*
[Background character]: Typical Mary Sue
[Kylo Ren]: Huh, that was easy
Uh, blow 'em up
*PEW PEW PEW*
Anyone want ton ton for dinner?
*UNEXPECTED DEVELOPMENT*
*PEW PEW PEW*
The Empire is shutting us down!
Lousy ANTI-JEDITES!
*BOOM BOOM POW*
*To upbeat music* It's not the end, friends
Don't say goodbyyye, friends
Is that a teearrr, friend?
In your eeeyyyyyyeee
*GOODBYE*
I'm all right, kid.
So, Rey is captured and interrogated by Kylo Ren
...only to have Rey interrogate him
[Kylo Ren]: Why do you seek Skywalker?
Why do YOU seek Skywalker?!
[Kylo Ren]:  He's a jerky uncle who didn't let me play with the dark side!
*Deep breath*
You have the Force!
I do?
Well, then
you will leave me with a weak-minded Storm Trooper so that I can escape
[Kylo Ren]: HA
Joke's on you, that's what I was going to do anyways
[Weak-minded ST]: Hey
Release me
[Weak-minded ST]: 'Kay
[Snob]: Meanwhile, Finn meets up with his old friend Poe
HEY!!
Surprised I'm alive?
No, I saw the trailer
[Snob]: While Solo meets up with his old flame, General Leia
Leia, I saw our son
Han, I know there's still good in him
He just Jackson Pollock'd a cantina with a bunch of space Nazis
He's a little past grounding at this point
Please promise me that you'll try to win him back
PROMISE
...All right, I'll try to win him back
Also, can you fill out these insurance forms?
Okay
And close up these bank accounts
All right
Also wear this red shirt, I really think it screams "you"
Abrams movie, why not
OOOHH I know you can do it! *giggles*
*Suspenseful music*
[Critic]: So then Finn sneaks aboard their base and forces the Captain of the Storm Troopers
to lower the shield
Lower the shield
*DING*
Into the garbage chute, I haven't seen Gwendoline Christie performin'
I think this one speaks for itself
[Critic]: They run into Rey but also into Kylo Ren
who Solo decides he's going to confront
I decided I'm going to confront
Have I ever told you that you're like a mentor to me?
...Christ, I've no chance
[Critic]: So Solo approaches his son
who takes his mask off to reveal that he's actually a pretty good looking guy
Then why the hell does he wear a mask?
...Well, the dark side does seem to be anti-pretty people
Son, I know we haven't seen each other in years
and there's people pointing guns at us and
I know I haven't given you any new reasons to come back
But... I would like you to come back
Um, before I answer
could you take another few steps forwards?
Oh, sure
Your mother misses you, son
I miss you too
And if you forget for a minute that both the writer and I
wanted me to die in Return of the Jedi
Well, it would be great if you could-
HEE
*UNEXPECTED DEVELOPMENT*
*Dully, in unison* What a surprise.
I love you
*softly* I know
[Han Solo]: Great shot kid that was one in a million
*THUD*
[Critic]: So after the old mentor is killed
a bunch of ships fly in to stop the giant planet-destorying ball
that's about to blow up the base where Leia is
while a lightsaber duel takes place with a villain
who seems torn between good and evil
NONE OF THIS IS SOUNDING FAMILIAR IN THE SLIGHTEST?!
LIKE, AT ALL?!
Hey, you're the one who keeps living in the past
having Harvey Korman in drag teach the dreidel
Spin! Turn! Spin! Turn!
Spin spin turn HUAAAAH
3,000 years of beautiful tradition from Moses to Sandy Koufax
you're GOD DAMN RIGHT I'M LIVING IN THE PAST!!
Oh come off it Critic, you're not even f**king Jewish, man
I converted to Jewbacceyism the minute I married Mrs. Jarjar!
[Jarjar, off-screen]: Dreidel, dreidel, dreidel
I made you out of HUAAAAAAH
[Critic]: This does bring up a good point though
As similar as these scenes are to the past
there's not as much investment in them
We cared for the Death Star battle in the other films because we knew Luke Skywalker
We knew Lando Calrissian and we knew the emotional stakes
Here, we have Poe in this space battle
who hasn't had a lot of screen time
And we don't really know the consequences of either base blowing up
The bad guys always seems to make a bigger base after one is destroyed
and we're not sure if the majority of rebels are on the planet this time
or if they're spread out
Even the lightsaber duel seems kind of underwhelming
We only have one scene where these two have any real connection
and while it's a good scene, it's not really enough for a climax
With the other ones, they talked and discussed their history while fighting
"Your powers are weak, old man."
"I was the student, but now I'm the master."
"You are not a Jedi."
"Obi-Wan never told you what happened to your father."
Here, it's:
Join me!
Mnah
And that's it!
You get more dialogue out of a mime screenplay!
Oh, please! When has J. J. Abrams ever repeated anything in his sci-fi franchise-
I can't even finish that
[Snob]: The fighters destroy the base
causing Kylo and Rey to be separated
Here's to figuring out how we're related!
I say cousins!
And I say siblings!
OOHHH can I be related to Lando?
No
Wha-- come on! Everyone else is related!
[Critic]: So the not-Death Star is blown up
Rey travels to see Luke Skywalker
and she meets him on top of a mountain where she hands him back his lightsaber
*triumphant, swelling music*
So... it was good!
But did it really have to be so similar to the other movies?
Aww, come on, if you honestly see a connection between
an evil dictatorship
chasing a droid with secret plans
landing on a desert planet
where a wide-eyed youth comes across it
follows in the footsteps of a mentor
who has a connection to the villain
being controlled by a shadowy overlord
only to lose that mentor
while discovering a surprise father-son relationship
leading to a battle against a giant, round weapon
that destroys planets
and is about to destroy the base of a heroic resistance
but is stopped just in time
resulting in our main character leaving to train
with an old wise master from the past
Well then that's just silly
I just don't get it!
Why would they, after all these years, do something this similar?!
EXSQUEEZE ME
BUT MESA GOTSA KNOWHA
*AHEM COUGH COUGH*
*Sophisticated voice* Thank heavens, that finally passed.
Whuh... that's not your real voice?
Ohoho nonono, that's just a phase my race goes through
You see, we all start off whiny and annoying
but then we hit a certain age where we become quite charming and brilliant
The rest of my family will hit it soon enough
but until then, I thank you for indulging in all my insufferable antics.
um
No problem?
Now, let us prepare for our wonderful holiday.
Oh, ohoho dear
There appears to be feces on the floor
Let us step around that
Wow, that actually made things a lot better.
Well, yeah. I'm trying to make up for the sins of the past holiday special.
So that's why you did so many things that the other one did?
Exactly!
If I want to move forward with more specials, I have to prove that I can do a regular one okay.
So I stick to the formula, only this time I do it a lot better.
SHIT this is a metaphor, isn't it?!
Pretty much!
*frustrated growl*
[Critic]: I guess it does kind of make sense when you really think about it
After so many years of people hating the prequels
the filmmakers had a lot to prove
so they had to demonstrate that  they could do something that looks and feels like Star Wars
before they could forwards with anything different
Sure, a lot of it's on repeat
but it's done in such an entertaining and whimsical way
that it's still really enjoyable
And who knows? Maybe the new stuff that should've gotten more attention in this film
will get attention in the next film
[Snob]: And besides, they've done practically every other plot thread the other movies have done
there's not many left
leaving it open to new ideas in upcoming films
It's not a classic but it doesn't need to be yet
It's the reintroduction of an old friend
who've taken a beating
and just needed to show that he's gonna be okay
before he accomplishes better things
Well said, Snob
Well said.
But Critic, I still don't understand!
What is the true meaning of HHNRKKnukka?
Well
Just touch the magic ball and I'll show you.
*slurring* You're all... like family to me
just touch the goddamn ball
*woooo wow wow wow*
Leia! You made it!
Oh, I wouldn't miss this holiday for the world.
Leia, my friend here would like to know the true meaning of HUAAnukka.
Would you kindly explain it to him?
Of course.
*sentimental piano music*
We-
Are you gonna take it, or
You need to hold it for a month.
A month? But next month is January.
YOU KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS?!
SHYAMALAN MONTH!!!
*party music*
KEEP IT UP
*stilted acting from The Happening* What? No!
At the end of the day you're still not as big a disappointment
as Smut Williams
*outbreak of laughter*
HUAAAAnukka
Hey! Doug Walker here doing the charity shout-out
and this is one that I've known about for a while
given them money too and it's really, really good
and for some reason I've never bought it up before
and I don't know why but I'm doing it now
'cause it definitely deserves the acknowledgement
It is Mercy Corps
Uh, this is a humanitarian global organization
that goes around and specializes in saving people in every meaning of the word
They feed people, they go fix infrastructures that need fixing
They get people water, they rebuild places that have been destroyed
whether from war or natural disasters or whatever
They'll do tech start-ups, they'll fix bridges that are broken
Even land rights. This is an organization that does everything
Everything they do is just focused on making people better and trying to help them out
and going to places where they have a ton of disadvantages
and making it so that they can be strong again
And the nice thing is is that they just don't stick to one location
They travel everywhere, all around the world
42 countries altogether
It's amazing how much work they put into this!
It's kinda like a team of Supermans, all they do is go around and just try to help people
by any means necessary
I have no idea how they do it or how they can get all these people together
to do all these various things but they do and it's phenomenal.
Definately, definately take the time to check out their website
look at their YouTube page as well
See all the good that they're doing and see if you're willing to donate
'Cause man, they do it all and all that they do
is amazing
Go, check it out, show your support